The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALAN V. OPPENHEIM: OK.
In the last several
lectures, we've
been discussing the
Fourier and Z-transforms.
And we've seen in
particular that the Fourier
and Z-transforms
provide us with a set
of important analytical tools
for representing discrete time
signals, and also for dealing
with discrete time systems.
We saw, for example, that
through the use of the Fourier
transform or the Z-transform,
we could convert convolution
in the time domain
to multiplication
in either the frequency domain
in the Fourier transform
case, or more
generally, in the Z
domain in the Z-transform case.
Now one of the things that
it's important to recognize
is that for the most part,
the Fourier transform
and the Z-transform are
primarily analytical tools.
That is, it would
be hard to imagine
implementing, for
example, a discrete time
system by first
computing the Fourier
transform of the
sequences, multiplying
the Fourier transforms
together, and then computing
the inverse transform.
One of the reasons that that's
obviously a difficult thing
to do computationally
is that we saw,
as we discussed, for example,
the Fourier transform,
that the Fourier
transform is a function
of a continuous variable.
That is, omega in
the Fourier transform
is a continuous variable.
So that, in fact, if
we wanted to compute
the Fourier
transform explicitly,
we would have to compute
it at an infinite number
of frequencies.
Similarly, we have a situation
like that for the Z-transform.
Well, today I'd
like to introduce
a third transform,
which I'll refer to as
the discrete Fourier transform.
The discrete Fourier
transform is similar in style
to the Fourier transform
and the Z-transform,
as we've been talking about,
in the sense that more or less,
the discrete Fourier
transform maps
convolution to multiplication.
Also, there are
properties of Fourier
transform-- the discrete
Fourier transform--
that are similar to the
properties of the Fourier
transform and Z-transform, as
we've been talking about them.
But the discrete
Fourier transform
is different than
the other transforms
that we've been discussing in
a number of important respects.
One of the respects, one of
the reasons that it's different
is that it is a transform that
can be explicitly evaluated.
And consequently,
it is important,
not only in the analysis
of discrete time systems,
but also, as we'll see, in the
implementation of discrete time
systems.
That is, many digital signal
processing algorithms,
as we'll see, actually involve
the explicit computation
of the discrete Fourier
transform, which
is the Fourier transform that
we're about to introduce.
Now let me try to explain
a little about what
the discrete
Fourier transform is
before we look at it in detail.
Basically, the discrete
Fourier transform
is related to the
that we've been
discussing in the sense
that it corresponds to samples
of the Fourier transform,
or more generally, samples
of the Z-transform.
Now that requires that we
impose some restrictions
on the sequences that
we're representing
through that transform.
And as we'll see, it turns out
that we can represent sequences
that are of finite length.
That is, only have a finite
number of non-zero samples.
We can represent those sequences
by samples of their Fourier
transform.
Those samples then correspond to
the discrete Fourier transform.
Well, there are some
issues that arise
in looking at the discrete
Fourier transform,
or DFT, as I'll refer to it.
And a number of these
issues relate to the fact
that the discrete
Fourier transform
has properties that are somewhat
different, and also somewhat
similar, to the Fourier
transform properties
that we've been discussing.
There are lots of
ways of introducing
the discrete Fourier transform.
And the one that I guess I
find the most interesting,
and the most satisfactory, is
to relate the discrete Fourier
transform to the
discrete Fourier
series for periodic sequences.
And in particular,
relate the notion
of finite length sequences
to periodic sequences.
Well, let me explain in
a little more detail what
I mean by that.
Let's consider, first
of all, a sequence
x of n, which I'll restrict to
be a finite length sequence.
The sequence, for example,
one example indicated here,
has a set of non-zero values
only over a finite range
of the argument n.
Here is a sequence that
is of finite length.
And I've chosen to refer to it
as a sequence of finite length
capital N. 0 outside
the range from little n
equals 0 to little n
equals capital N minus 1.
It's 0 outside that range.
It's interesting,
just as an aside,
to note that for this
particular sequence,
it's also actually 0 outside
the range from little n
equals 1 to capital N minus 1.
And in general, obviously, if
I talk about a finite length
sequence of length
capital N, I can also
refer to it as a finite
length sequence of length
greater than capital N. That
is, the important statement
about the sequence
being finite length,
of finite length capital N, is
that the sequence values are
0 outside the range 0
to capital N minus 1.
Although obviously,
the sequence could also
be 0 inside that range
for some of the values.
Now the basic notion that
leads to the discrete Fourier
transform, or one way of
looking at the discrete Fourier
transform, is to recognize
that if I have a finite length
sequence, as I
have here, I could
construct from that sequence
a periodic sequence.
And let me denote the periodic
sequence by x tilde of n.
In general, by the way,
when I refer to a sequence
with a tilde on it,
that will always
correspond to a
periodic sequence.
And let me construct
this periodic sequence
by simply taking the
finite length sequence
and repeating it over and over
again with a period of capital
N. In other words,
I can construct
the periodic sequence, x
tilde of n equal to x of n
plus x of n shifted
to the left by capital
N and x of n shifted to the
right by capital N and 2n, 2
capital N, and 3
capital N, et cetera.
In other words, just
simply taking this sequence
and repeating it
over and over again
with a period of capital N.
So obviously I can generate,
from a finite length
sequence, a periodic sequence.
And in fact, I could get
the finite length sequence
back from the periodic sequence
by simply extracting one period
of this periodic sequence.
In other words, I can get x of
n back from x tilde of n simply
by multiplying by unity for
n between 0 and capital N
minus 1, and 0
outside that range.
Now the important point here--
there are a couple
of important points.
One of them is that if I have
a finite length sequence,
I can turn it into
a periodic sequence.
If I have a periodic
sequence, I can
get back to the
finite length sequence
simply by extracting one period.
Or what that essentially
says is that there really
isn't much difference between
a finite length sequence
and a periodic sequence.
That is, a finite
length sequence
is defined by capital N values.
A periodic sequence is also
defined by capital N values
because once I specify
a single period,
then I don't have
any more degrees
of freedom in specifying
the rest of the sequence.
And that's an important point
to keep in mind, particularly
as we go through the
next several lectures.
A finite length sequence is very
similar to a periodic sequence
in that both of them are simply
defined by capital N values.
One way to think of
that, by the way,
is to think of taking a finite
length sequence of capital N
values.
Instead of drawing it
along a straight line
as I've done here, imagine
taking this finite length
sequence and wrapping it
around the circumference
of a cylinder.
So we start with the finite
length sequence and just simply
display it wrapped around the
circumference of a cylinder.
As we run around the
cylinder, over and over
again, what we see is the
periodic sequence x tilde of n.
So in a sense, the
periodic sequence
is just simply like the
finite length sequence,
but wrapped on a cylinder
instead of laid out
in a straight line.
And that's also a
picture that will
recur several times as we
go through the next several
lectures.
So we can generate the periodic
sequence from the finite length
sequence.
We can also recover
the sequence x of n
from the periodic sequence by
extracting just one period,
as I've indicated here, x of n
is x tilde of n in the range,
little n between 0
and capital N minus 1.
And it's equal to 0, otherwise.
Or what we'll use as a
convenient form of notation
for that is to express x of
n, the finite length sequence,
as the periodic sequence,
x tilde of n multiplied
by another sequence, which I'll
denote as R sub capital N of n,
where R sub capital
N of n is just
simply a rectangular sequence.
So R sub capital N of n is
1 for little n between 0
and capital N minus 1, and
it's equal to 0, otherwise.
All right.
So it's important to
begin, at this point,
to think of finite length
and periodic sequences
as more or less the same
type of thing in the sense
that it's easy to go back and
forth from one to the other.
Now, why is this point
of view important?
Well, we know certainly in
the continuous time case
that a periodic time function
can be represented by a Fourier
series.
In the discrete time
case, a periodic sequence,
likewise, can be represented
by a Fourier series.
And the idea, that
is, the key point
behind the discrete
Fourier transform
is that we can use the
Fourier series representation
of the periodic sequence to
represent the finite length
sequence.
That is, that, in
essence, provides
a Fourier kind of representation
for a finite length sequence.
So we have the notion then
that the periodic sequence x
tilde of n has a Fourier
series representation.
We can compute the
discrete Fourier series
of this periodic sequence.
And as we'll see--
not in this lecture,
but as we'll
see in more detail
in the next lecture--
it is discrete Fourier
series representation
of this periodic
sequence that is
what we'll call the discrete
Fourier transform of x of n.
So let's begin then
with a discussion
of the discrete Fourier
series of periodic sequences
with the idea that we'll be
applying that representation
to the representation of
finite length sequence.
And that representation
is what will
correspond to the discrete
Fourier transform.
OK.
So we want to talk about
the discrete Fourier series.
We're considering a sequence x
tilde of n, which is periodic,
and it's period
we'll call capital N.
In the continuous
time case, we know
that if we have a
periodic time function,
we can represent it as a linear
combination of harmonically
related complex exponentials.
That's the Fourier
series representation
in the continuous time case.
And I'll just simply
state without proof
that the same kind
of relationship
holds in the discrete time case.
That is, we can represent a
periodic sequence x tilde of n
as a linear combination of
complex exponentials, which
are harmonically related
to the frequency.
Or equivalently, the
reciprocal of the period,
so that this forms a
general relationship
for a discrete Fourier series
of a periodic sequence x
tilde of n.
That is, these are the
harmonically related
complex exponentials, just as
we form linear combinations
of harmonically related complex
exponentials for the Fourier
series in a
continuous time case.
What are the Fourier
coefficients?
Well, it's, of course,
these capital X tildes
of k, which we'll have a little
more to say about in a minute.
Well, notice that I haven't
specified as of yet any limits
on this summation.
And in particular,
what we need to examine
is how many distinct
periodically or harmonically
related complex
exponentials there are.
Well, let's take a look at
the complex exponential,
the set of complex
exponentials e to the j, 2
pi over capital N, little nk.
And the statement
that I want to make
is that these complex
exponentials are periodic.
Of course, we know that
they're periodic in n.
But they're are
also periodic in k.
As we vary k from 0
to capital N minus 1,
we generate all of the
possible harmonically related
complex exponentials with
this fundamental frequency, 2
pi over capital N.
Well, we can see
that very simply by substituting
in for k, k plus capital N.
And then recognizing
that we can break
this complex exponential
into the product of two
complex exponentials e to the
j, 2 pi over capital N, nk,
and e to the j, 2 pi
over capital N times
little n times capital N.
Well, these capital N's
cancel each other out.
This factor is then e to
the j, 2 pi times little n.
Well, any integer multiple
of 2 pi up here then just
simply reduces this to unity.
So that, in fact, e to the j,
2 pi over capital N, little n
times k plus capital
N is the same as
e to the j, 2 pi over
capital N, little n times k.
Well, that shouldn't be
surprising, actually,
because that's a point
that's come up time
and again as we've been
going through these lectures.
The point being that
sinusoids in the discrete time
domain, as we vary
sinusoids in frequency--
we've seen time and again,
in the range 0 to 2 pi--
in fact, those are all the
sinusoids that we can generate.
And if we keep
going in frequency,
we just simply see the
same ones over again.
So this is a
consequence of that.
But for the discrete
Fourier series,
it says an important thing.
It says that in forming
the discrete Fourier
series, once we've used the
complex exponentials for k
between 0 and capital
N minus 1, we've
used all the
complex exponentials
with this fundamental
frequency that we have.
And if we keep
going with k, we're
just simply going to see the
same complex exponentials over
and over again.
What does that say about
the discrete Fourier series?
It says that in
the representation
of the discrete Fourier
series, the limits on this sum
don't range from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
They run simply from 0
to capital N minus 1.
So once I've looked at
these linear combination
of these complex
exponentials for k between 0
and capital N minus 1, there
are no new complex exponentials
with that fundamental frequency
that I'm able to find.
So this then is the form of
the discrete Fourier series.
There's one additional
insertion that I'd like to make.
And this is just simply
a normalization factor.
I want to multiply this by 1
over capital N. Obviously, that
doesn't make any
essential difference.
It's just a factor
for normalization.
And it plays a role which is
similar in the continuous time
case to the role that 2
pi or 1 over 2 pi plays.
All right.
So here we have the
discrete Fourier series.
It's relatively
straightforward to show
that you can obtain the
Fourier series coefficients x
tilde of k from x
tilde of n through
an inverse relationship,
which is the relationship
that I've indicated here.
So this is then, in essence,
the inverse discrete Fourier
series, or equivalently,
the relationship
for obtaining the
discrete Fourier
series coefficients from the
periodic sequence x tilde of n.
Now notice that I've happened
to write the Fourier series
coefficients with
a tilde over them,
implying that those coefficients
are themselves periodic.
Well, are they periodic,
or aren't they periodic?
What I've been saying here and
what I've been saying here--
and I've spent a long
time saying this--
that there are only a finite
number of complex exponentials.
Once I've looked at them in the
range 0 to capital N minus 1,
I've seen all the
ones I can see.
And in that sense, the
Fourier series coefficients,
x tilde of k, are finite.
That is, there are only
a finite number of them.
Well, the important point
is that there are only
a finite number of
distinct coefficients.
Also in this
relationship, whether I
consider these as
periodic or not periodic,
I still only use a
finite number of them.
That is, I only use them in
the range k equals 0 to capital
N minus 1.
And how I choose to interpret
capital X tilde of k
outside the range 0
to capital N minus 1
is going to have absolutely
no effect on the evaluation
of this summation.
Well, it turns out to be
convenient to interpret
the Fourier series coefficients
as being periodic in k.
Well, in fact, the relationship
as I've written it here
makes it evident, in this
particular relationship,
that the coefficients
are periodic.
In other words, if I substitute
in for k, k plus capital N,
then I'll get back exactly the
same relation that I have here.
Because of the fact that e to
the minus j 2 pi over capital
N times little n
times k plus capital
N is equal to e the
minus j 2 pi over capital
N times little n times k.
So that if I simply examined--
I asked from this relationship--
what does capital X tilde of k
plus capital N come out to be?
If I simply substitute that
in, then because of the fact
that these two complex
exponentials are the same,
I'll find that x--
capital X tilde of k
is equal to capital X
tilde of k plus capital N, k
plus 2 capital N, et cetera.
That is, it's a periodic
sequence, although I only
use one period of
it in reconstructing
the periodic sequence
x tilde of n.
I choose to do that
mainly because of duality.
That is, mainly because
it is convenient to think
of these as a periodic
sequence so that I
have one periodic
sequence representing
another periodic sequence, this
being a periodic sequence in k
with a period of capital N, and
this being a periodic sequence
in n with a period
also of capital N.
So now with a discrete
Fourier series,
there's a duality
in the, what we
could call the time domain
and the frequency domain.
And the duality is there
in part because we've
chosen to represent, or think of
the Fourier series coefficients
as periodic, as a
periodic sequence,
although we only use a
finite number of those values
in actually explicitly
evaluating the Fourier
series for x tilde of n.
Well, this then is
the Fourier series.
Let me finally rewrite
it one other way,
which just introduces some
notation that's convenient.
Let me define w
sub capital N as e
to the minus j 2 pi over
capital N. In that case,
then just simply rewriting
the Fourier series,
we have x tilde of
n is 1 over capital
N, the sum of capital X
tilde of k, w sub capital
N to the minus nk.
And the Fourier
series coefficients
expressed in terms
of capital W sub n
is the sum of x tilde of n,
w sub capital N to the nk.
Well, the discrete
Fourier series
has properties,
just as the Fourier
transform and the Z-transform
has had a number of properties.
And again, as we've done
with the other transforms,
I won't spend a lot
of time on the details
of either enumerating the
properties or proving them.
But let me just
illustrate one or two
to give you some idea as to
what these properties involve.
Well, first of all, as we've
talked about in the Fourier
transform and
Z-transform cases, there
is a shifting property that
tells us how the Fourier series
coefficients of a
periodic sequence
are related to the Fourier
series coefficients
of that sequence shifted.
And in particular, it turns out
that if capital X of k, capital
X tilde of k are
the Fourier series
coefficients for
little x tilde of n,
then the Fourier
series coefficients
for that sequence shifted, that
is, little x tilde of n plus m,
corresponds to multiplying
the Fourier series
coefficients by w sub
capital N to the minus km.
Shifting the sequence involves
multiplying the Fourier series
coefficients by a complex
exponential, which
is what this is.
And that is similar to what
we've seen with the Fourier
transform, shifting a sequence,
multiply the Fourier transform
by a complex exponential.
And the Z-transform, we had
exactly the same situation.
We have a dual
relationship, which
expresses the result of
shifting the Fourier series
coefficients.
If we shift the Fourier
series coefficients,
the result is multiplication
by a complex exponential
of the original sequence,
little x tilde of n.
In fact, one of
the things that's
true with the discrete Fourier
series that hasn't been true
with the Fourier transform
or the Z-transform
is there is a strong
duality between the time
domain, the discrete time
domain, and the Fourier
or frequency domain.
In particular, we begin with
a discrete periodic sequence,
and we end up in the
Fourier domain with, again,
a discrete periodic sequence.
In fact, something
to think about
is the fact that the Fourier
series coefficients we've said,
or we've chosen to interpret
them, as being periodic.
That implies that they
themselves have a Fourier
series representation.
And something to
think about is, what
are the Fourier
series coefficients
of that periodic sequence?
All right.
So one important point then
is that we have this duality
between the two domains.
And essentially, any property
that we have in the time domain
will find the dual
property in the frequency
domain for the discrete
Fourier series.
And that will the
hold true when,
later on in the next lecture, we
talk about the discrete Fourier
transform.
Another useful property,
which we've also
talked about for the
Fourier transform,
are the set of
symmetry properties.
And in particular, if
we consider x tilde of n
to be a real a
periodic sequence,
then there are
symmetry relationships
between the real part
of the Fourier series,
and symmetry relations for the
imaginary part of the Fourier
series.
In particular, we can think of
expressing the Fourier series
coefficients in terms of
their real part plus j
times the imaginary part.
And the symmetry
relationships that result
are that if the periodic
sequence is real,
then the real part of the
Fourier series coefficients
are even, x sub R of k is
equal to x sub R of minus k.
And that's what we
refer to as the property
of, in the case of the
Fourier transform, the Fourier
transform being even.
We can also write this
in another way that
will become important
when we talk about
the discrete Fourier transform.
In particular, since this
is a periodic sequence,
since s sub R of--
since x of k is
periodic, obviously
it's real part is
also periodic--
we can replace k by k
plus capital N, or k
minus capital N. And
we can rewrite this
as a statement that says
that x sub R tilde of k
is equal to x sub R tilde
of capital N minus k.
It shouldn't be
particularly evident
why we want to do that here,
although it becomes important
when we apply some
of these notions
to the representation of
finite length sequence
and sequences in the
discrete Fourier transform.
Likewise, for the imaginary
part of the Fourier series
coefficients, we end up
with a symmetry property
that says that the imaginary
part of the Fourier series
coefficients are odd.
And again, as we did with the
real part of the Fourier series
coefficients, we
can rewrite this
to say that x sub i tilde of
k is equal to minus x sub i
tilde of N minus k.
Finally, we can, in
a similar manner,
look at the magnitude of the
Fourier series coefficients
and the angle of the
Fourier series coefficients.
And just as we've seen
with the Fourier transform,
the result that we'll
find is that the magnitude
of the Fourier
series coefficients
are even, an even function of k.
And the angle of the
Fourier series coefficients
are an odd function of k.
So we have symmetry
properties like we
had with the Fourier transform.
An important thing to keep track
of at this point, because we'll
want to refer back
to this when we talk
about the discrete
Fourier transform,
is that in talking about
the property of even or odd,
we can either talk
about it as we do here,
or in terms of a shift--
that is, in terms of a
statement that x sub bar of k
is x sub R of capital N minus
k, which essentially relates
the evenness of this
periodic sequence
to the relationship between
values within one period.
Finally, we have another very
important property, which
is the convolution property.
This is a property
that, again, we've
had for the Fourier transform
and for the Z-transform.
It's a property that
states, essentially,
that the convolution of
two periodic sequences
results in the multiplication
of the discrete Fourier series
coefficients, with just one
minor twist, which again will
become important when we relate
this to the discrete Fourier
transform.
In particular, we have
a periodic sequence,
x1 tilde of n.
And here its Fourier
series coefficients.
A second periodic
sequence, x2 tilde of n,
with its Fourier
series coefficients.
And what we'd like
to ask is, what
is the periodic
sequence, x3 tilde of n,
whose Fourier series
coefficients are
the product of x1 tilde
of k and x2 tilde of k?
In other words, if we multiply
the Fourier series coefficients
together, what is the sequence
that that corresponds to?
The answer, which involves just
simply a little bit of algebra
to verify, is that
the resulting sequence
is a sum of x1 tilde of
m, x2 tilde of n minus m.
Well, that looks exactly
like a convolution
with one important difference.
And that is that the
limits on the summation
don't go from minus
infinity to plus infinity
as they did in the
case of the Fourier
transform and Z-transform.
Ordinary linear
convolution, as we've always
been talking about
it, involved the sum
from minus infinity
to plus infinity,
of x1 of m, x2 of n minus m.
Here we have, as the
limits on the sum, 0
to capital N minus 1.
The summation is carried
out only over one period.
We have also a dual property, in
other words, the property that
relates the Fourier series
coefficients of the product
of two sequences to the
Fourier series coefficients
of the individual sequences.
And because of the duality now
that we have between the time
domain and the frequency
domain for the Fourier series,
these Fourier
series coefficients
are, again, the convolution
of the two Fourier series
coefficients for x1
of n and x2 of n.
There's a normalization
factor, 1 over capital N.
But again, the limits on the sum
involve 0 to capital N minus 1.
So this is slightly different
than the convolution
as we've been talking about.
It is referred to
generally, and we'll
be referring to it as
a periodic convolution.
The important distinction being
that for this convolution,
it involves a summation,
not for minus infinity
to plus infinity, but simply a
summation over only one period
of the periodic sequences.
Well, to drive this
home, let me just
show you with a simple example
what these sequences look like,
and in particular, what
the shifting involves,
and apply an
interpretation to that.
And so let's return
to the view graph.
What I'm indicating here
is a sequence x2 tilde
of m, a sequence x1 tilde of
m, and to form the convolution
of these two sequences.
What I would like to do is
generate x2 tilde, in general,
of n minus m, multiply that
by this, by x1 tilde of m,
and then sum up the
result over one period.
Well, I'm indicating,
by the way,
in blue, just one period
of this periodic sequence.
And similarly in
blue, one period
of this periodic sequence.
So let's examine, first
of all, the sequence
which corresponds to replacing
this by x2 tilde of n minus m.
And let's do it for
the specific case
where little n is equal to 2.
So I've illustrated here the
sequence x2 tilde of 2 minus m.
And to generate this
sequence from this one
involves essentially two steps.
The first step is to
flip this sequence over,
that's replacing m by minus m.
And then the second step is to
shift the sequence by an amount
little n, depending on
the argument that we
want to stick in here.
Now this is the
result of doing that.
We can think of this as having
flipped this sequence over,
and then shifted it by
two points to the right.
And the result is then
this periodic sequence.
An important thing
to keep in mind,
or to look at-- and again,
this is a point that we'll be
emphasizing in much more
detail in the next lecture--
is that as we examine
these blue points,
we could think of
having gotten those
by simply flipping
one period of this
and circularly shifting
that, circularly shifting
those points, simply in the
range 0 to capital N minus 1.
That's an interpretation
that will become much more
evident in the next lecture.
But then to form the
convolution of this sequence
with this sequence, we then,
after having constructed
x2 tilde of n minus m,
carry out the multiplication
of these two sequences.
The result of that
multiplication,
I've indicated here, so that
for this particular example,
these three points get
multiplied by these three.
These four points,
rather, get multiplied
by these four values.
The rest of the points in that
one period get multiplied by 0.
And then finally, to
evaluate the result
of the periodic convolution
for little n equal to 2,
we sum up those values in the
range 0 to capital N minus 1.
So it operates very much like a
linear or ordinary convolution,
as we've been talking about
over the last several lectures.
The important difference is that
the summation is carried out
just simply over one period.
All right.
Well, that completes
the discussion
as we want to present it, of
the discrete Fourier series.
As I indicated at the
beginning of the lecture,
our objective was eventually
to develop a Fourier
representation for finite
length sequences, that is,
the discrete Fourier transform.
And in the next lecture,
what we'll want to do
is take the ideas of
the discrete Fourier
series, as we've
talked about them here,
and apply them to the
representation of finite length
sequences, resulting
in what we'll call
the discrete Fourier transform.